hey welcome back everyone
so um this is our second to last session
this afternoon
uh it's my pleasure to introduce uh
rupaul mahmoud
rupam is an assistant professor at
university of alberta
he's also a canada cfr ai chair
and he's also the director of the
rlai laboratory at the university of
alberta
before after completing his phd
in 2017 uh rupaul also spent some time
working in industry at kindred ai in
toronto
where he worked on actual robots with
reinforcement learning
but what i find very interesting about
uh rupaan's research is that he's really
trying to
to push some of the reinforcement
learning techniques that we've heard
about
on wednesday in adam stock and really
use these techniques at scale on real
systems
and what that means is that the kind of
rl pursued by rupaul
and rupaul's group is facing uh some
very
particular challenges uh namely that of
learning
um in a continual manner on on a robot
and running continuously if you remember
adam on wednesday was talking about
the fact that uh the rl algorithms that
he's working
with are those that uh keep on learning
all the time
well i believe that rupam is pursuing
this vision as well
and is really trying to push this as far
as he can on real robot
so i'm very excited to see um to see
this today
and hear about some of the progress that
have been made here
as usual you can ask questions in the q
a and i believe that rupaul
will take your questions about halfway
through his talk
thank you
thank you pierre lou well
about time to start i'm excited today
to share how extremely interested i am
to have robots around us help us
and live together with us and for that
today i'm gonna
give you a perspective of how we can see
reinforcement learning
rl as a natural consequence of our quest
for automation
and in in addition i'll also briefly
talk about
some of the foundational methods of
reinforcement learning
and the approaches that we can take to
bring reinforcement learning
applications to real-world robots
so talking about automation
let's talk about machines so
conventionally machines used to
help us with physically laborious tasks
but nowadays they're also helping us
with mentally
laborious tasks uh physically laborious
tasks
examples should be traveling or
lifting heavy items mentally laborious
task
examples would be keeping a steady speed
or staying within a lane now that's
a pattern shift in the kinds of tasks
that are solved by machines
and there is another paradigm shift
that's happening
now which is the in the ways tasks are
solved by machines
so what is that shift
so traditionally humans
they have been in charge of all levels
of
performance improvement iteration and
testing cycles of the machines
the machines did not improve by
themselves humans tested the machines
figured out how to improve them
and updated it in the next iteration
and for that humans they needed to have
a comprehensive understanding of how the
task is accomplished
and then they baked it in uh
to the machine so for that human needs
to have the insight of the
final desired outcome or behavior
so that's the traditional way of
building machines but in the new way
machines are increasingly in charge of
the performance improvement decoration
and testing cycles
and for that we equip the machines with
adapting capabilities
that lead to automatic improvement so
instead of providing
instead of breaking in the final desired
outcome as
humans we tend to now provide the
improvement mechanism
and there is a drawback of that also
which is that
instead of having a comprehensive
understanding of how
the machine is accomplishing the task we
rather understand the thing that we
provide which is a mechanism of
improvement sometimes it is hard for us
to understand
what is the final outcome
so in short automatically improving
machines they are
emerging but why is that why are they
emerging
it's out of necessity so let's take an
example
um for an example we take kindred's
robotic product called sword and here we
are looking at the clip from
2018 so this machine
this robot is deployed in
different warehouses of of different
afro companies such as gap and carters
and each unit they look like this
and its job is to pick an a merchandise
item from the beam
scan it and then store it to a
particular
designated copy so that's the job
it does and you're looking at the video
that is not sped up so it is the real
speed
it's quite fast it was quite fast back
then it's even faster now
and really accurate
so in this machine
do we need automatic improvement if we
apparently it looks like it's a
repetitive task and
it might be mundane and we can have all
the insights that are needed
to bake in the machine and
let it perform its task but then we'll
be wrong to think that
because it turns out that human workers
they use their
common sense knowledge and and their
background
uh knowledge to accomplish this task
while facing many different kinds of
changes in the environment although this
looks like a quite a structured
environment however all
kinds of changes may happen over time
such as
the kinds of objects to pick their
colors their weights
they may change over time so one
particular example
we can take where say there is a
quite heavy item that is above the load
capacity
of the robot cannot be picked but all
the other items are underneath
that item so the other smaller items
they can be picked but
they cannot be even seen because they
are operated by the heavy item
a human worker would simply push the
heavy item
and pick these small ones so
and that's the kind of uh the situation
that can occur
anytime unexpectedly and it might
the the engineers who designed this
robot might not have
perceived this new situation beforehand
in this kind of situation we want the
robot to automatically figure out
what is the right thing to do probably
through trial and error
and even if the human engineer perceived
this particular situation there might be
many other situations
that might be coming and expect
unexpectedly and when we might not be
able to predict beforehand
and and precisely this is why the
traditional way of
building machines where we bake in the
final
desired behavior cannot scale
and especially because if we look at the
whole industry robotics
industry there are many different robots
we want to use
to solve newer stuff and in each case
baking in the solution
that's not scalable that's why
automatically improving machines are
necessary
and to draw
an analogy we have to look at the
animals because it's a new technology
and the the existing technologies they
were mainly based on breaking in
so we may wonder what example we have
of a machine that can automatically
improve its performance
and the example would be us and all the
other animals
so animals they are adaptive and
resilient
and when they have a wish they find a
way to
achieve it and
for example with animals who we are not
told
by others how to solve each problem we
newly face
but we still know through trial and
error how to improve
our ourselves so
that's the best analogy we have right
now
and apparently learning machines
when you build them they will also
operate more like animals
now the question is how would we build
them
and before i proceed i would like to see
if you have any question
do you have questions so i think we
don't have the questions for now uh
but once again uh to the participants
you can uh
ask questions to uh rip on as usual for
with the q a
perfect
to find an approach for building such
animal-like machines
and also look at animals again
let's think about how we describe
animals and inanimate objects
to describe inanimate objects we usually
rely on
physical attributes or composition
that often suffice to describe a
physical object such as a granite
boulder
but for describing an animal behavior
if we just talk about its physical
composition and attributes
that are often not enough
instead we tend to impute purposefulness
or goal
in in the system in the animal
such as a cat here is trying to catch a
ladybug
so goal is a compact way of describing
animal behaviors
and that's also key to design
animal-like machines so in this new
approach
instead of providing the solution
directly
we provide a specification of the task
or the goal
and the mechanism for improving
performance with experience by an agent
so in the old way we used to make in the
desired behavior of an agent
in the new way we provide the goal in
terms of the sensory motor experience of
the agent
and then provide a learning mechanism
that uses experience to arrive at the
desired
behavior and we also talked about
how the second approach is more scalable
than the first
to see it more concretely let's imagine
n different systems that we have to
build
we need to build they solve and
different tasks
which is illustrated by different shades
of blue
so they are different goals solving
different tasks
and the systems that are solving these
tasks they have different bodies as well
some might be humanoid robots some might
be drones
and as they have different bodies and
growths it is uh
reasonable to believe that the
decision-making
process would also be of the generative
behavior
would also be different for these
different systems
and that is illustrated by these
different shades of colors
for the agent now
if we take the conventional approach
then our goal would be to
come up with the final desired behavior
we think about what that would look like
we build our inside and encode it
directly to the system
and that is difficult and each time
there is a new system
we might need to do that again
and if the solution can be transferred
they can only be transferred to a small
class of systems
instead in the other approach
we don't necessarily need to provide
the uh an effective behavior we
say we start from completely scratch or
kevlar
here the goal would be instead to come
up with a learning mechanism
and and if it is generally described
then we can provide the same learning
mechanism
to each of these systems the same single
learning mechanism
and then the agent uses the system in
each
case and experience to improve its
performance over time
and then arrive at the final desired
behavior
and which was the the final thing that
we want out of the agent
but that's not what we provided we
provided instead the mechanism
and as you can see here the work is much
less
might be in a sense very hard because
it's a
research question how to come up with
learning mechanisms but if we can
come up with the general learning
mechanism
then we don't have to actually figure
out the particular
final result behavior for each different
system
so that's how this approach is also more
scalable
okay now i think i can see there are
some questions
okay i'm gonna read them
okay sebastian is wanting to do
like an email is really the solution is
it a consensus in the field or
is some researchers looking elsewhere
well it's not necessarily it's a good
question right
so it depends on the reasoning and the
reasoning looks like what i gave here
which is
uh that if we build animal like machines
it means that we don't have to uh
take care of them all the time and
anytime there is a failure
we are not needed to take care of them
or or improve
uh its mechanism animal has its uh
self-improvement mechanism
uh to take care of any failure and that
was more
scalable so the argument is about
scalability
and in that way it seems appealing now
the
the one question might be is there any
other way to achieve a scalable system
that would be a great question
okay how do we train an animal like
system
observing an email yeah so
that's something i'm going to cover
briefly and some of it was
also covered you'll see that it's the
as we arrive at uh machine learning
mechanisms so that's the way to train
like an email ricardo
is it like doing a digital twin
i'm not quite sure about the uh
reference here see that
which aspects of the speaking algorithm
pipeline does the kindred
sword uses rl for gripping motion
planning control binning
it's a great question in different
places the the whole
iteration of picking scanning and
storing
it is divided into sub problems and
there are also you can see the whole
process in a hierarchical way
so rl is applied in in some of those sub
problems
okay again one system is specific to one
animal or in general
we are talking we are talking about uh
the general way that animal learns
rather than one particular animal
different animals they behave
differently
but we can
agree that they all look like they can
learn
from their experience so we are talking
about that underlying mechanism
instead of the the uh particular
behavior they
come up with for these different animals
land how do we know when a goal is a
goal
by itself and when we need to break
goal into some goals
right so in this talk we'll mainly talk
about like
providing a goal and we will go through
examples of like first
describing the task using plain language
so that is one description of the goal
but then converting it into more
technical terms
using reinforcement learning framework
all right perfect
let's go back
okay
so in order to
make machines that are like animals that
can improve
them by any males we talked about
instead of
breaking in the final laser behavior we
are talking about
providing a goal and the learning
mechanism
and that can be done within the rrl
framework
and it's also one of the simplest
specifications
of an agent so in this framework
agent here it's there's a box for it it
contains the computational decision
making process for
this goal achieving system and
it interacts with an environment by
taking
actions and
this interaction it also happens on a
moment by moment basis or uh
with discrete time step it can also
so each time step was the duration of it
a time step can
also be quite long
it can be on a moment moment basis or it
can be
something such as like uh when the train
arrives at the destination
the time step can be complete so that
is something determined by the designer
so now we are thinking of having a
particular task that we want to solve
how we can formulate that problem using
the rl framework
so first first thing to note is that
there is a clear separation
between the computational decision
making process and the rest of the world
and they interact with each other using
discrete time steps
the duration of that is also determined
by
the designer
now that's something we determine
uh what is the definition of each time
step
at each standstill the agent will take
an action
and the environment it maintains uh some
internal state
and we assume it to be markovian in the
sense that
if we know the kind of state it's not we
don't need to
know previous states to be able to
predict
the dynamics of the environment most
accurately
and in exchange
for receiving an action the environment
changes its internal state however
however the agent does not
get to see the state of the environment
the state of the environment for an
agent it could be the rest of the world
which contains
agents just like itself
so for us it would be like i am one
person in the world in
uh involves billions of other persons
and
uh all they are thinking the state of
their brain that can
actually will comprise the state of the
whole environment and i cannot perceive
all that
so what an agent ends up perceiving
is just an instant instantaneous
snapshot
of the state we call observations so
that's what we
receive as an agent
and the goal that we were talking about
that is fully specified in
rl through a reward signal that the
agent receives
on each time step
so that defines the interface of an
agent
and a system designer will design this
interface
and stick to it and given this interface
then the goal the objective of the
designer
is to come up with the learning
mechanisms to put in this box so that
the agent can achieve
maximum amount of expected future
aggregate reward
so the goal of the agent is to maximize
the amount of
reward in future in a aggregate it
receives
and the the objective of the of the
system designers
or our rl researchers is mainly to come
up with learning mechanisms
to put here so let's take an example
uh again the sword robot
the kindred it solves this peak and
place problem
we talked about so how do you formulate
that using
rl framework we will
first think about uh time steps
and also one thing to note is that this
task
can be divided into
a sequence of independent episodes or
trials or
attempt at storing objects to
a particular copy so it can be seen as
an episodic task
and each episode will contain many
different time steps
at each time step the agent will take
actions now what will be the action
the actions will be the things that make
the robot move
grasp and drop so it will be the motor
commands that are sent to the
gripper as well as to the joints of the
arm
to make it move now
the observation will contain
for example the joint positions and
velocities
of each of the motors or other joints as
well as the gripper
and also this system it contains many
cameras
so the image is coming from the camera
they
will also constitute the observation
vector
now what will be the reward function
now here i wanna pause and ask you
what you think should be the reward
function the goal is to
store an item to a designated copy
that can be a good example of reward
function
oh i think i can see q a
so there are more questions here
virgo animals are driven by curiosity as
well
how can we generate the curiosity driven
learning rather than we've already been
learning
so they are related qacity you can see
that as well
as an intrinsic reward and there are
different works that focus on this
particular topic
but they can still be done within the
general rl framework
but hey what is the difference between
animals and humans from the perspective
of rl
well we are part of the animal kingdom
as humans we are also animals
we do different things uh different
animals do different things
uh from that perspective uh
it's it's a matter of degree i would say
tolga has a question
fatima what is the intersection of deep
learning and reinforcement learning
that's a
good question i'll cover a little bit of
that how can we
use both of them together brock don't
animal receive some rewards from
biochemistry yeah
internal to the agent based on their
observations rather than strictly from
the environment
does rl have a mechanism for this yes
so just because the diagram shows that
the reward comes from the environment
that doesn't mean that
it cannot be based on the observation we
may as well see
that your function to be a map from the
observation which is also provided by
the environment
so there's no conflict there so nana
are you saying that a better
representation specification of the task
is
something that will boost learning
significantly keeping everything else
in the rl framework the same yes it is
important to
specify the task better yes
if we don't define the action space
properly the observation space properly
the agent might not have the right set
of experience
to be able to improve its performance
yes told again animal intelligence is
shaped
by evolutionary considerations like
survival
buildings uh preserving
an energy budget those considerations
shape
the earlier rewards but i think at some
point
we build our own rewards hierarchically
from these primal rewards how do we
account for such
dynamics of the evolution right
so uh that's a great question
uh it's not clear that we have to do
exactly what evolution did to animals
in the end the what's the underlying
objective here the underlying of the tvs
is to come up with a mechanism
to improve performance that
that automatically improved performance
it does not need
an authority or a designer to take care
of it
the process that automatically improves
the performance evolution you can see
that as one particular mechanism
no reason to believe that we must
go through exact same path the
inspiration we're taking from animals is
that
look we already have a machine that can
automatically improve performance
so again should we let our agents
augment redefine rewards
in order to improve the specificity of
the reverse signal
that would be something we should
consider yes
so but how about my question that is
what should be the reward function
any answer
i guess you guys can hear me
yeah we can hear you repub okay
right exactly for the sort robot
how can we define the reward function
yeah number of correct sorts
but the reward a function is determined
on a part-time step basis
it's a signal that the agent receives
every time step so what would be that
value every time step
the agent cannot receive like no number
it must receive some number scalar value
uh ruban so we have tolga here i think
who would like to
ask a question out loud so uh if uh
jackie can unmute toga
yes that's good thank you pierre um i
think
some of these questions have already
been answered um
um so there's that but um i guess to
answer the question
um given the sparsity i think
and a primal one would be just
like correct sorting is maybe a reward
but each each individual
configuration of the robot getting there
to a certain certain point could be some
reward too
um that being said um even if you don't
do
other things like the way evolution did
don't you think we should at least
consider
preserving an energy budget in robots
because like if you've seen
boston dynamic robots there's this dog
that's
still just like jumping up and down
where it's staying
it's not moving it made me think like
that's not
what a intelligent animal like a dog
actual dog would do
when you're idle you would just sit
still because you don't want to burn
extra calories so do you think that
should be part of
our reward mechanism the preservation
great question so the reward function
should capture what the designer has
in their mind to be the task
right so if the task involves like
conserving the energy which
seems like should be the case for most
robots it should be part of the
reward right so
but the focus here is for the designer
to think about the task
from first principles what they want to
achieve
right so what they want to solve for the
task
what should the uh solution look like
so uh yeah now i have some answers
so for example if i take a told answer
it
then it would mean a reverse being zero
every time step
and plus one only when
an item is dropped correctly to a cubby
but then to encourage the robot to
achieve it as fast as possible we might
have them some
discounting some discount factor
discounting the reward with the value of
which would be less than one
now i also like a sonnet's suggestion
to have negative reward say minus one
every time step
right until the item is currently sorted
or say there is a timeout try too long
now it's time to give up uh
if maddy if you are moving towards the
correct sword
minimize the distribution uh between the
hand and location of the slot yeah
yeah that can be a sub goal
with the penalty yeah and then
christina how do we design robust reward
functions for
practical rl applications what about
cases when it is not trivial to
mathematically formulate these
reward functions well in many cases the
tasks
they look like like you can know as a
designer you know when the task is
solved you can at least at the very
least design the reward function
that way that minus one every time step
and the episode ends when the task is
solved so it seems like
designing the reward at least in one
complete way is not
difficult but typically comes from like
designing a reward that is also helpful
for the
agent to learn so i'm gonna go back
to continue with my slides and come back
to the questions
again later so
in rl much of what we do is we try to
find the learning mechanisms for the
agent
now what mechanisms we are gonna
use we can look at machine learning for
that
which is a powerful alternative to
traditional programming
uh here is an example of a traditional
uh algorithm
which takes x as an input and is
expected to
produce y as an output
but in traditional programming we humans
write the mapping encode the mapping by
hand
so this is the mapping and we in order
to do that we look at some examples of
inputs and outputs sex might be 1 2
3 4 and y
might be 2 4 6 8.
by looking at those examples we've been
the inside
what might be the mapping from here one
might reasonably conclude that the
mapping is
y equals to x then they write the
program right here
that multiply the input by two and make
that
the output but instead
in machine learning a function
relationship
can be learned from data for example
we can parameterize the function with a
particular parameter theta
and then come up with a learning
mechanism or algorithm
that will look at the data itself
instead of letting the humans look at
the data
and then figure out what should be the
desired
parameter value for mapping x into
the desired output y correctly
so this is the same data set
and the designer will have to specify
what parameter class that we are looking
at here it is a linear
class a linear function of the inputs
and then the learning mechanism would
work like this if you look at each
input output samples and based on that
it will change its
values for example it might start with a
value of 0 but over time
it will slowly approach to the correct
value
of 2. now
particularly in this case the loss
function
was a squared error between
the true output and the output of the uh
function now in machine learning it's
quite common to instead of desi
writing the program by hand we start
with the loss function
the goal is specified uh as a loss
function
in in many cases in machine learning and
in this particular case is a regression
problem so it's
we can take the squared loss and for
mechanism you can use
an algorithm such as stochastic gradient
descent which will update
its current parameter by computing the
gradient of the
loss and taking the decent direction
modulated by the step size parameter
and in this particular case the exact
gradient
looks like this however we now have
automatic
differentiation packages that
where we can simply specify the sample
loss
and the gradient will be calculated
automatically
so can we use these techniques for
reinforcement learning
so machine learning is a powerful tool
for functional approximation
so how would we use those we actually
can
if the agent is a function in that case
we can see
the agent to be a map
from the observation to the action for
simplicity now we are assuming the
observation is same as the environmental
state
so we call it a policy which is uh
represented as a
probability distribution and then
we can determine an objective and come
up with a corresponding sample loss
and again go with the stochastic
gradient addition algorithm
to update the parameters so that is
possible you can borrow
ideas from machine learning which are
also
very close to how i we described
the new machines should be designed
which is by providing the goal
in here in this case the loss function
and providing a learning mechanism
and then if the agent is a function then
we can use functional approximation
tools but the question is whether the
agent is indeed a function
for that we go back to the diagram again
and redraw agent here
it has the same interfaces as this agent
it takes observations and rewards as
inputs and
speeds out actions as outputs we have to
come up with
the computational decision making
process to put right here now the
question is whether this is
this can be a function it should be a
function
right which is to say that the optimal
way of
behaving optimal actions
are should they be a map from the
observations
so to understand this situation
let's take this as an example of an
instantaneous
observation this is one example of ot
so the agent is a dr someone who drives
potential drive cigar can also walk out
of the car
and through a mounted camera this is
what is observed
defense that can be seen through the
windshield
now the question is just based on this
observation can we determine the optimal
action
as a map is that possible
now well the the reasonable answer is
like it depends
right so it depends on the state of the
environment
so what is the situation right now the
this instantaneous
observation it confuses two different
states
at least two different states of the
environment one is
where the driver just
entered the car so the right thing to do
is probably to
turn on the engine and back up
and the other state is where the driver
probably
has just parked in so the right thing to
do is to
get out of the car so it depends on the
state of the
environment world which is not captured
in this particular single snapshot
so in general practically the agent
is not a function it's rather a stateful
process
the function is a stateless process it
is the same output even the same input
that's not gonna be the case for many
agents
because observation is not itself a good
representation of the state
so that's a blocker because now it seems
like
the function approximation tools we
cannot directly use
fortunately we can actually divide
a stateful process into at least two
functions and a memory for the internal
state
so there can be two different functions
one is the state representation update
function
which based on an internal memory
tries to represent what is the state of
the environment
right now and
that agent state can be fed to another
function
and there's a policy function for which
now the goal is to
map the agent state to the optimal
actions
so those are two functions then for each
of them we can
individually apply functional
approximation tools for pulse you can
use policy learning and for state
representation update we can use
representation learning mechanisms
so this is a complete
diagram for a model-free reinforcement
learning agent
now however
modern deep rl methods they learn both
functions
typically end to end using neural
networks
and and using the same loss function
rather than using two different learning
mechanism and loss functions
so here the observation is mapped
through a neural network to produce
the action now we can see it
as containing two different maps the
observation is mapped first
to the agent state and which is then
mapped to the policy
but the key here is that this whole
neural network
is a fit for neural network which means
that it does not have an internal memory
and in many cases simply doing that
using that
works because many of the problems that
we address
right now especially in simulations the
observation
vector is rich enough to represent the
state of the environment and if it
does not then we can simply add
observations from from the past that is
to
say we use a history of observations
so that's the situation and but just by
doing that
right now we can we do have learning
mechanisms
that can be applied to many different
goals and embodiments here there are
three different
embodiments simulated creatures and
different goals this one the goal is to
reach the red dot by the fingertip and
for
these two the goal is to move to the
right as fast as possible now they are
now generating behavior based on a
randomly initialized neural network
but using the same learning mechanism
it can improve its performance over time
and
end up solving the task effectively
so that's possible and we have also seen
that
our agents they are
promising solution to robotic tasks
and we have seen that before for example
here
now we are looking at a roomba docking
to a charging station
and its behavior is driven by a default
script
provided by the manufacturer and
it's behaving slowly and steadily to
approach the
charging station but we can use the same
approach
that we just saw for the simulated
robots which is start
from a randomly initialized neural
network
and then use a learning mechanism to
arrive at a desired behavior
here it's a learned behavior which
is talking to the charging station
and here is another one which is
approaching at an angle
and then realigns and you can as you can
see that this learned behavior
is quite different than the hand
engineered one this one is more
animal-like
and also faster
so that's the situation
now you can do that all that so for
an exercise let's take another task
maybe before that you can also look at
is there any pressing questions
uh
let me let me carry on a little bit and
then we can come back
so let's take at this task it's a roomba
pool task
it's just a name i gave to a fictitious
task
here imagine you have a pool table on
top of which there is
a roomba that can move around
and it has an onboard computer and a
camera attached to it
and the goal is for the roomba
to push these billiard balls
to their associated pockets they cannot
go to
any pocket that the roomba chooses
it needs to be uh associated with the
particular pocket and that will be
determined by
the barcode that are on them so
then the robot the roomba has to
get closer to a ball recognize the
barcode and from that it will know
from which pocket to which pocket it
should
push the ball toward and then accomplish
the task
and now note that it's it's not really
that easy because
the barcode might not be seen uh
from the position from from where the
roomba is looking at the ball rather it
might need to get closer to the ball and
position itself correctly even then
the barcode might be occluded it might
be facing
downward then it needs to move the ball
around
to reveal the barcode and if it moves
the ball too fast it may end up getting
inside the wrong pocket
it has to be done with sophisticated way
but also as fast as possible
so let's look at a sub goal from here
which is we we're not gonna push the
ball to a particular pocket we'll just
recognize the barcode
so that's the first goal
then we'll have to go through the
exercise again
how would we design the task so first
we'll
we can see this again as an episodic
task where the robot is attempting at uh
recognizing the barcode every time
so one important thing to note is that
the agent
as i mentioned before is the
computational decision making process
not the physical device it's better not
to think of the roomba
as the agent which is a quite
easy to confuse and and we often say
that the roomba is doing this or that
the agent is the computational process
and from that perspective
we may very well see the physical device
for the roomba itself as part of the
environment
and then the task has many independent
trials each trial is about recognizing a
barcode as soon as possible
but there is also a timeout so an
episode ends when there's a
scan or after 10 seconds
now within an episode there are multiple
time steps so each time step it contains
an observation observe act cycle
that is executed repeatedly and each
cycle
is a fixed time of 40 milliseconds
so that's something we have to choose
say as a designer that's what we chose
and then with the reward signal can be
-1 every
cycle or time step and the objective
would be
to maximize the accumulated
episodic reward which is also known as
the return
so does it make sense if you think about
it
uh if we maximize the return it is also
the same as for the roomba to be able to
recognize a barcode as soon as possible
right so if you uh if the roomba ends up
recognizing a barcode in 10 time steps
then the return will be minus 10 which
is higher than
minus 100 a return that you'll get if
you
recognize the barcode in 100 time steps
so here is another question say for a
timed out
episode that uh we want to know how much
return the agent received how much
return would that be
i'm throwing this as a question to you
say in a particular episode
the agent was not able to scan
so timeout occurs what will be the
return
so that it yeah
here says minus 250 perfect
how do you calculate well i calculated
that's why
it seems right but let's do it like
the the the whole episode if it times
out it will be 10 seconds long
each time it's taking 40 milliseconds
right so you can just divide 10 by
0.04 you're gonna get 250 so it will be
250 time steps long each time step you
are going to get a reward of minus 1
so the total return will be an
accumulation of that which will be minus
250
perfect
so for an action
we are going to take uh the
wheel velocities so each wheel they can
be
actuated and a motor command of velocity
can be sent
the range is actually between minus 500
and plus 500 but we
restricted it between minus 150 and 150
millimeter per second for a reason that
i'll describe later
and then the this action will be exerted
once every 40 millisecond
and the robot controller will receive
this command and it will keep executing
that action until it receives a new
action the robot controller also streams
a sensory packet once every 15
milliseconds
they say images they arrive once every
30 minutes again then
how are we gonna
build the observation vector we can
look at the sensory packet the rumba it
has
distance the infrared distance sensors
around its body
to know where the obstacle is or
something that it
can be a physical object there are six
of them we can
get the values from those six distance
signals but it
also has uh bumping signals
uh two in the front so you can get
values from those and also the kind of
velocities
and then the images from the camera
those
all together will build the observation
vector
so the action
now the question is how that will be
drawn it can be
as it's a it's a real continuous uh
variable between minus 50 and plus 50
we can draw it based on a normal
distribution which has a particular
mean and variance but then we'll
get only one velocity we can do the same
for the
other wheel then we get another action
and together we get an action vector
that can be seen as drawn from based on
a multi-dimensional normal distribution
but it can be between minus infinite and
plus infinite
so we can clip it between minus 1 and
plus 1 and then a scale
between 150 and plus 150 before sending
to the robot controller
then the learning problem becomes
learning these parameters of the
distribution
the mean and the variance because based
on that the action is
being drawn and we can represent
these parameters as a map from the
observation
where the image is passed through a
convolutional neural network and
concatenated with the
values that we get from the road stream
and then it is passed through
multiple layers of dense neural network
and then
in the end we get the distribution
parameters
and the learning mechanisms such as two
custom gradient descent we can use to
learn the parameters
of this neural network and
when it works it should end up finding
the right mean and standard deviation
that will provide the optimal action
given
the context which is the observation
now i'm gonna skip the details
of the mechanism but it's mainly
to arrive at an algorithm called
reinforce
it's a batch version of it it consists
of two
loops that actually represent the
the life of an agent where each time
step is the
iteration that happens inside the inner
loop where the
agent observes an observation vector
completes the forward pass to draw an
action
and sends it to the robot wait for a
while and then after that receives a
reward
and that iteration total will be 40
milliseconds long
and after each episode it completes all
the returns and after
bk episodes it computes a loss function
uh sample loss and based on which it
makes a struggle to gradient is an
update
now that's a valid algorithm for
improving
the behavior of a reinforcement learning
agent
the modern deep rl methods they are much
more sophisticated than that
and much more complicated than that but
at the core
they look pretty much like this with a
loss function
and perhaps an hdd update
so and using so an example would be
an algorithm called ppo proximal policy
optimization
such an algorithm can solve many complex
tasks within a few million
samples these three we have seen before
they are actually
these uh clips are generated by training
the agents using ppo
as well as for the roomba
talking to the charging station so
that's possible
now the problem is if we want to use it
for the real world policy optimization
methods that also
typically starts with this kind of
behavior
which is at the beginning they wiggle
randomly
do not generate goal-oriented behavior
and as it wiggles so randomly that's
also
the reason we needed to confine the
range of actions between one
minus 150 and plus 150 because if we
allow the full range
there will be more volunteer and
overheating of the motors so that's the
problem
and that is a big problem for
reinforcement learning agents to be
applied to real-world robots
in some cases they may still learn in
some cases
uh they may generate unsafe behavior
and and even if they're safe within a
confinement
there might still be the problem of like
taking too long
can we wait actually long enough
so that the learning can happen in the
real world
so that is often addressed using the
idea of pre-training a policy
and two popular approaches one is where
a human expert
provides demonstrations which are then
used
to learn the uh the initial policy
right so this is not done using
often the exact interface that we have
shown
sometimes it has to be violated
by other by different means such as
providing the samples directly that are
not coming from the environment
inside the agent but that's a good
approach
to avoid this kind of initial
exploration
another approach is where human experts
they develop
a simulator a realistic simulator and
learning and the initial exploration
everything
happens mostly within the simulator
and when the simulation is done then the
policy
is transferred to the reload so this is
simulation
and after learning happens it's a real
robot
and it's behaving according to a
transfer policy
policy that is learned completely in
simulation that's also another popular
approach for pre-training that avoids
all these time consuming and potentially
unsafe
behavior initial exploration
so this approach is known as symptoms
now these are great these are what we
need
in the cases where we cannot wait long
enough
or we cannot have a behavior that can be
potentially
unsafe now
even then we need robots after we
pre-train using one of these methods
we need robots to continue to learn over
time
right so think of an application where
we are deploying robots at a massive
scale
there might be like billions of units if
each of them
starts to fail and require human experts
to provide the
new demonstrations or a new simulator
until it knows how to come
out of that situation or a failure mode
then it
there will be billions of robots asking
for human self that cannot scale
so we still need the robots to
learn from its failure rather than ask
for human interventions
now and in some cases it is actually
possible
so here is an example again
of this initial behavior but if
we let the robot continue to learn
it may learn many different skills
before it learns how to solve the harder
problem which is talking to the
charging station for example first you
can learn how to just move forward
which is a useful skill to learn which
will be useful
to solve the problem of talking to the
charging station but when it learns how
to
move forward it can be used to
solve another intermediate problem which
is to align with the docking station
from arbitrary positions but not dock
yet it does not dock yet
just aligns but it is already a
substantial improvement toward the
problem of docking to the charging
station but in the end it can use
all these skills to learn to dock
from arbitrary positions
and here as you can see it now talks
properly and if you notice it is
actually starting from
a very awkward starting
position unlike the previous
clip that we showed where it was mostly
starting from the same
region where it is mostly looking toward
the docking station
here it is near the uh charging station
and looking away
is one of the hardest positions to start
with
but when you learn different skills
and utilize them to solve the harder
problem it learns to solve that problem
actually more robustly
so this is an ongoing experiment of one
of my students muhammad al said
now this is to say that it might be
possible
because if you think about it i said the
ppo takes like few million
steps to solve the moderately complex
task and if you
are running room by 40 millisecond cycle
time
it would take about um in a week
you're gonna get more than five million
time steps which might be just enough to
solve a problem like this
now the question remains i'm going to
wrap up soon
now the question remains in what cases
we can already have these kind of
applications of continually learning rl
systems
are they possible right now i just
showed an example where it's possible
right now
to learn how to talk to the charging
station
but how do we think about these
applications and in what case is
possible in one case it might not be
possible
right now so here i have put
different ai applications in a space
that is defined by two dimensions
the expected cost of exploration
and the level of human interactions
now both if they are high can be
problematic for continuous
continually learning early ages
here there are many different
applications such as space robots
which might not have much human
interactions
but the exploration cost might be a lot
and for ai governments it might be
both that are massive in some cases such
as device power management systems or
somewhere house robots such as the one
that we
saw the sort robot from kindred
we might be able to scale down uh the
level of human interactions
and the the cost of exploration
at least during the initial deployment
through engineering practices such as a
canary
release or rollout and then slowly
scale it up if that is possible
in your application then we can have
continued learning our system right now
on the other hand cases such as
ai based governance if it turns out to
be the case that such
uh governance it can impact
the whole mass population and the
exploration
then can also if there is a mistake it
can be quite costly
we should be quite
cautious about this kind of applications
because
right away we cannot start using
continual learning our
systems so i hope uh
this might help us uh determined
determine whether a particular
application
is uh suitable for continuous learning
our systems
now this is the penultimate slide
some advice one advice
for the for those who are from the
industry and
thinking whether it's applicable think
about whether the performance of your
product
or the set of future products could
scale well with data
then it utilize real-world exploration
whenever it's safe to do so
how to do that aim for a deployment
strategy where human interaction and
exploration cost can be scaled down
and those who are thinking of joining
academia or
starting a phd for those
i want to point out the fact that a
robot that runs for
five years in the real world such as in
your lab
you could learn a lot if you need
numbers in five years
with 40 millisecond time steps
a robot can gather more than a billion
samples
that is enough to be able to solve about
100
tasks that are as complex as complex as
say the docking problem and incidentally
five years is also
the same about the same amount of time
that takes to
finish a phd so if you are planning to
do a phd in robot learning
consider running that grand experiment
let the robot run
for the whole time and learn
that the robot learn over time more and
more how to solve more and more complex
tasks
then one good objective
for the phd program can be to discover
the mechanisms that are essential for
the robot
to learn more and more composters
automatically instead of
us taking care of providing the task as
also was one of the comments from q a
that how can we have automatically
generated
goals so if we can discover such a
mechanism
that can divide the the final
or the most primary goal in an automatic
way and generate sub goals
and let the robot
learn from experience more and more
complex skills
and knowledge so that would be a great
step
now we spoke about automation
and arrived at rl so it's reasonable to
wonder
how does the far end of ai and
automation look like
so it seems like we will end up
developing animal-like machines
like we already have in software
uh but i'm here i'm talking about like
physical robots
they may behave like animals and
learn like animals and live with us
now in parallel i believe we will also
more and more figure out that animals
and conscious beings
their desire to be autonomous and free
and when we put these two together then
we can easily deduce that
subjugating and controlling intelligent
beings
they are questionable not only that they
are also not practical
and not scalable like say
controlling another being that's kind of
like micromanaging
lots of effort from another person it's
not practical
also not moral
and the great thing is i believe there
can be a viable economy full of free ais
just like right now we have a viable
economy full of free humans
there is already already an example an
evidence that it is possible to have a
viable economy
full of reagents so why can't we have
free ais
as well and then the far end
might look like this a universe full of
many many ai's trillions of them roaming
around
the universe with overlapping goals and
empathy
and it would be great to live with them
not to think of them as replacement but
the problem the best way to think of
them
is as our natural progression and true
air
all right thank you
thank you everybody um i think we may
have like five minutes left so perhaps
if you'd like to pick one uh
question among the 15 open questions
yeah in the q a session i think uh
uh the participants were really active
15 open 18 answered
[Music]
that's that's really great i really need
to congratulate everyone for
asking so many questions it's fun for
everyone
that's great yeah i was
enjoying answering this question but
then i realized that
okay i have to move on i wish i could
read all of them
um
we do have the breakout session with
europa coming up also
that's right yeah we could use that as
well
okay how about children
what are your views on explainable ai
could you please suggest some
interpretable or
explainable rl methods me i would
suggest you
to look up the literature i don't work
on it it's a very important
area because as we will have more and
more applications we need
uh our methods to be explainable
and and i
in addition to that i also
need to see a level of
caution among among us that is like to
what extent we are expecting them to be
explainable
and again i'll i will seek analogy from
animals to what extent they are
explainable that might be a good way to
think about like
what is the right level of
explainability we
need to seek from ai
okay can i perhaps ask a
uh three minutes question and then we
conclude can i
say that basically if i understand your
proposal correctly
i think you're trying to say that um
the way to go to improve sample
efficiency in rl
is through continued learning which
has to do what i guess with
compositionality and the reuse of skills
can we say that this is the main
hope you think that's right
so in a way i'd agree with those who
would say that
well sample efficiency uh obviously we
need to look at like simulations or
demonstrations
like when we learn from those uh it
becomes
it will use much less number of samples
from the real world
but i'm looking at a situation which is
inevitable
which is that a robot in the end will
encounter a new situation
and the question of sample efficiency
will still be there
but will not have the the option of
intervening by providing demonstrations
or simulations now we will have to
improve our learning mechanisms that are
being used
to learn by the agent in real time so
compositionality is important
acquisition of skills and knowledge and
utilizing them that's important
which might be done using model based rl
and and background planning so those are
the methods we have to
rely so but the the process which is
uh the one one thing here was to not
give up on real-world learning because
it will becoming inevitable so we have
to work hard on
on increasing the sample efficiency of
our our
learning mechanism that will be used in
the end
okay can i just um pull up on from my
outsider's perspective on on continued
learning um
so you know and i gotta say ripple and i
have been kind of growing in the same
environment
the kind of sort of rl so whatever we
talk about computer learning
i think i see it the way that rupam has
been describing it but there are people
working on continual learning as well in
the
deep learning setting and i think for
them computer learning uh
is a lot synonymous with catastrophic
forgetting do you see any of these uh
tools
and and advances in that kind of
continued learning
being useful for what we're trying to
achieve in rl
absolutely so when we utilize when i
spoke about utilizing uh already
acquired
behavior skills knowledge then
the problem of catastrophic interference
appears
right so so if we use the the mechanism
that i mentioned
was the gradient descent in the most uh
natural way
it turns out that they are not best at
utilizing what is already learned
so that that is actually one of the main
problems to
to continue uh our research on on this
kind of life for
lifelong learning agents so this is one
of the main problems we must address
what they are doing
uh should be done and should be part of
our ultimate set of learning mechanisms
thank you rupam so uh on this we're
going to conclude
i think nadine will copy paste the
questions that were left unanswered in
the q a
and she's going to pose them in slack
and so republican if you have a bit more
time and you can have a look at the
remaining questions on slack that'd be
uh really appreciated and that's that
would perfect yeah
nadine was mentioning i think there'll
be more portuguese for people to
interact with you through
breakout sessions and other events so
thank you so much and
uh we see each other everyone in a few
minutes for the next talk by
chelsea fan thank you thank you guys